Robert, I've been thinking.
It's great you're helping all these random people and everything.
But that's not gonna fill that hole in your heart.
I am obligated to tell you these things.
I'm the only friend you've got.
Mac, Susan is gone.
Susan worked in a dangerous world.
I looked at the video of all the surveillance.
Something else went on in that room.
Who did this?
Whoever we're looking for are high-level assassins.
They're cleaning up.
Nobody is safe.
You have no idea what you just started.
You shouldn't have gone to war with us, McCall.
You got it backwards.
You're going to war with me.
The mistake they've made was they killed my friend.
There's no coming back from this.
We all gotta pay for our sins.